it's time for
moss or ross oh
[Applause]
okay here's how it's gonna work we're
gonna pick a random fact and we're gonna
pop it up on the screen and i have to
decide who it pertains to i'd love for
you to play along everybody and since
shining girls is going to leave you on
the edge of your seat if i get the
majority of them correct our audience is
going to go home with this amazing prize
to help you relax because boy do we all
need to relax in this world um there's
an intelligent therapeutic massage
device from the company lyric so i would
like to um
you know
help you all relax yeah yes
[Applause]
i'm gonna say but they only get it if
you're good at this game right thank god
i well let me try all right number one
let's see the first fact
okay fact one is i once got third place
in a demolition derby
[Laughter]
so our we have to keep a straight face
elizabeth which is tough it's tough for
me to keep a straight edge
[Laughter]
ross
i feel like it might be ross because of
like how and where you grew up
i'm going to go with ross
yes it is
[Applause]
yes it is
you're going to need like five of those
massage tools
okay let's see what's next i'm so
excited okay uh i once appeared on the
screen with hulk hogan
i'm going moss for this one
moths
[Applause]
let's take a look
yeah yeah
look at that kitty
[Applause]
it's probably like seven or eight
wow thank you
thank you very much that was the most
that's a whole suitcase to unpack it
starts somewhere i love that yeah some
of us start with steven spielberg but
some of us start with hulk yeah
i love hulk hogan
all right next factory
i've been alone to disneyland um
because i love it so much
oh i love that everybody is like
ross
oh gosh look at that innocent blinking
you know what's so weird is my instinct
is that it's moss but
oh god i'm going against the grain now
all right i'm going moss i'm going moss
[Applause]
by yourself yes
yes i grew up in la and sometimes there
wasn't anything to do and i did i went
drove to disneyland by myself oh did you
get a chair with me time i rode a couple
rides and i went home
i love it that's what it's there for
the happiest place yeah
we'll go with you next time okay thank
you
i think i was excited i had a car and i
could drive somewhere and i wanted
that's you know i was like i could drive
anywhere i want i'm going to go to
disneyland yes the world is your oyster
yeah handmaid's tale season five
explores freedom you go to disneyland
exactly we all have our idea of freedom
all right number four i know how to
install a lighting fixture
oh oh a little division here i see
i am going to go ross with this one
i'm very handy
i have a whole toolkit and everything
yeah i did a youtube tutorial and
learned how to do it you're also like a
walking pharmacy you're very handy
like don't ever underestimate ross no
i'm like mcgaver all right like i'll
just solve any problem
yes done
that is genius um have you ever said
that before no i mean one time well that
might have to be a whole thing yeah
let's sell a whole sitcom the gave her
here to solve the crime all right done
sold
um all right
we have one more my biggest fear is deep
water
i'm going moss
that's it
i think i'm doing pretty good yes did i
get any wrong
no you did not barrymore i know you did
it and you know what that means
that means you're all going home with
these dope really cool amazing lyrics
massage devices i'm taking one
and
rosie i love you so much
oh mossy i love you so much
this is such a dream come true for me
too are you kidding this really it
really really is i have these giant
pom-poms and they say elizabeth mom i'm
always going like this thank you let it
not be so long until we see each other
travel work pandemic let's not please
not okay good you can catch elizabeth in
the new series shining girls
streaming now on apple tv plus
[Music]
you